[Music]
okay so how's this for a christmas
surprise after a few gag gifts jalen
henry shocked her husband tony letting
him know she paid off his five-figure
mountain of student loans
that three
yeah i want you
walking around
tony said the family has tried to pay
off the student loans and become debt
free but never could which we can
identify with jayla saved up all year to
get rid of the financial burden that he
thought would last forever
i was planning on dying with it honestly
i was just astounded jawed dropped to
the floor still astounded i'm still in
disbelief it hasn't really hit me
completely yet he did tell me that i
don't even need to try to top it or even
buy him another gift for the rest of his
life
birthday gifts valentine's christmas
father's day
anything columbus day i don't need no
type of gifts
forever
good forever the henry's they have two
kids um they say their next goal is to
save up and work toward building their
dream home how about that for a while
what she was planning on dying with the
debt i know that's a lot of americans
americans
your gift is zero you owe nothing go
live i just how did she save up for it
was she like sneaking 20s out of
different places just cutting back on
something next yeah right for her
shout out to her right yes that she was
able to do that yeah but also just
knowing your partner is being is being
crushed by there's a weight yeah there's
a weight on them and i could help lift
it off that's right love that keyword
partner that's right you know it jamie
mucus